MaMartine Biron, Jonathan Trude,
AlAlex Castonguay bonsoir!
AÀ l'aube ce matin, je ne sais
papas si on va avoir le temps de
paparler de Monsieur Prudhomme,
mamais j'avais dit Alex que vous
dedevriez écrire un livre là-
dedessus et je vous dis
pupubliquement Martin que le
miministère Prudhomme... il y aa
unun livre à faire!
JeJe ferme la parenthèse, je vos
coconfirme libre!
AvAvortement, ça a bouillonné au
QuQuébec et à Ottawa beaucoup de
mamauvais côtés Monsieur Legault
etet Mme Anglade et Monsieur
DuDuhaime.
- - Est-ce que c'est normal
d'd'avoir un candidat
prpro-avortement au Québec
acactuellement?
- - Non. Ce n'est pas normal.
IlIl ne devrait pas y en avoir,
etet il n'y en a pas et
ilil n'y en aura pas à la CAQ.
DODOMINIQUE ANGLADE,
chcheffe, Parti libéral du Québc
- - Moi, je demanderais
àà l'ensemble des formations
popolitiques d'avoir clairement
dedes candidats qui ne sont pas
cocontre l'avortement.
- - Les gens ont le droit avoir
dedes convictions personnelles,
leles gens ont droit d'avoir
unune liberté religieuse au Quéc
etet ce n'est pas à M. Legault,
àà Mme Anglade ou à M. Nadeau-
DuDubois de décider qui a le drt
dede se présenter et qui n'a pas
lele droit de se présenter.
IlIl y a quelque chose de
trtrès antidémocratique.
C'C'est trois "wokes" qui sont
enen train de faire la promotion
dede la culture de l'annulation,
lele "cancel culture" où on déce
jujuste ceux qui pensent
cocomme nous qui ont le droit
dede présenter. Et pour moi,
c'c'est un précédent dangereux
etet j'espère qu'ils vont revenr
susur leurs affirmations
ququ'ils ont faites un peu
plplus tôt aujourd'hui.
- - On est passé à un woke à
trtrois!
EsEst-ce qu'il y a place aux
dédébats?
MoMonsieur Legault et Mme Anglae
didise qu'il n'y aura pas de
cacandidats antiavortement danas
leleur équipe.
- - Tous les partis politiques
auaujourd'hui visait Éric Duhaie
ququi a un candidat avoué qui dt
ququ'il ne légiférait pas, mais
ququ'il est ouvertement provie
c'c'est certain qu'il y a une li
auau pays et ce sont les provins
ququ'il applique et on voit que
leles provinces appliquent
didifféremment.
EsEst-ce que c'est parce qu'il a
plplus d'antiavortement dans
d'd'autres provinces que dans
d'd'autres, mais si on pose la
ququestion différemment, s'il ya
dedes candidats ouvertement
anantisémites qui disent: moi je
susuis antisémite mais je ne
blbloquerais pas l'accès aux jus
ouoù je suis homophobe, mais jee
blbloquerais pas le mariage gay.
C'C'est sûr que les gens s'ils
veveulent voter pour ces
cacandidats, ils peuvent le faie
etet se présenter, on est dans n
ététat démocratique, mais la
sisituation est que certaines
pepersonnes veulent prévenir ler
drdroit et c'est cela la situatn
etet l'enjeu.
- - Jonathan?
- - Soyons très juste pour
cocommencer, Éric Duhaime a répé
àà plusieurs reprises d'aucune
fafaçon il était antiavortementt
auaucune façon il aurait
l'l'intention d'agir contre ce
prprincipe est fondamental.
MaMais il veut aussi assumer
l'l'image que son parti projett,
il parle de liberté ici
cacandidats ont le droit de penr
cece qu'ils veulent et lui il ae
drdroit de faire fi de cela dans
lele choix de ces candidats, mas
sisi la liberté des autres parts
dede lui critiquer.
LeLe concept du métier
cuculturalisme, un parti comme
EÉric Duhaime serait très
crcritique du multiculturalismel
vava dire qu'au Québec on a des
vavaleurs communes et un socle i
dodoit être partagé et par
coconsensus, mais quand on parle
dudu droit aux femmes de disposr
dede leur corps, je pense que ça
fafait parti des valeurs communs
etet je vois une espèce de
didistorsion dans les messages
EÉric Duhaime passe
hahabituellement.
- - Il y a un large consensus de
gegens qui vont dans le sens de
lalaisser aux femmes le droit de
mamaîtriser leur avenir et leur
cocorps.
AlAlain?
- - Les frontières du wokisme st
rerepoussées je ne savais pas qe
çaça avait un lien avec
l'l'avortement.
C'C'est comme une espèce de mot
fofourre-tout qu'on utilise come
unun épouvantail.
IlIl y a une bonne différence
enentre avoir un candidat sur le
clclient personnel qui est oppoé
àà l'avortement et quelqu'un qui
enen fait la promotion et qui
tetente d'influencer son parti
popour faire bouger son Parti
sosocialiste et on stoppe les
crcroyances personnelles de
chchacun, on peut se présenter n
tatant que antiavortement mais a
dédépend ce qu'on veut en faire
susur la place publique.
MoMoi j'aime mieux savoir, que s
gegens veulent en toute
coconnaissance de cause en sacht
leles connaissances de cette
pepersonne, mais un patient le
drdroit de dire qu'il ne veut ps
dede ce type de personne ils ont
drdroit de décider que cette
pepersonne représente pas les
vavaleurs du parti et ça en fait
papas quelque chose d'abominable
nonon plus tout le monde n'est s
bibienvenu.
IlIl y a un chef qui décide il a
unune organisation qui recrute,
c'c'est légitime côté de Dominie
AnAnglade de dire que ces
cacandidats ne sont pas les
bibienvenus et Herrick Duhaime a
lele droit de dire quels sont ls
bibienvenus chez lui mais de làà
didire que ça a un lien avec
wowokisme...
- - Monsieur Trudeau à jongler
avavec l'idée, il a demandé à
MoMonsieur Duclos de légiférer,l
y y a deux francs; l'accès et iy
a a le droit qui est plus
cocompliqué.
EsEst-ce que c'est une bonne ide
dede légiférer.
OnOn va écouter Monsieur Trudeau
etet je vais vous demander si ue
bobonne idée.
- - Nous sommes en train
dede regarder exactement
cece qu'on peut et doit faire
dede plus pour assurer que
totoutes les femmes ont ce
lilibre choix à travers le pays.
EtEt en plus, j'ai demandé au
miministre Duclos et au ministre
IeIen de faire un suivi pour vor
c'c'est quoi le cadre légal
ququ'on pourrait améliorer.
- - Qu'est-ce que vous comprenez
dede la réflexion du premier
miministre?
- - Qu'on essaie de marquer
ququelques points politiques et
d'd'embarrasser les conservateus
dodonc on ressent les premiers
sésélects orales de la dernière
cacampagne on avait promis
cecertaines choses en matière
d'd'avortement s'obstine
prproblématique dans plusieurs
prprovinces de l'Atlantique.
- - Juste une précision; quand l
n'n'y a pas de chiffre ça ne vet
papas dire qu'il n'y a pas de
clclinique, c'est pour donner ue
ididée aux gens, allez-y!
- - Il n'y en a qu'une ou Princ-
EÉdouard et pas beaucoup en
NoNouvelle-Écosse, mais je pense
quque c'est une mauvaiaise idéee
lélégiférer sur le sujet au Cana
pupuisqu'actuellement ce débébat
n'n'est pas particulièrement
pepertinent, on n'a pas le même
sysystème politique ni les mêmes
popositions qu'aux États-Unis et
sisi on crée loi autour de
l'l'avortement on va devoir fixr
dedes règles comme la loi du fos
etet c'est plus facile pour un
paparti de modifier un projet de
loloi et d'avoir une légère
opopération en place comme
momodifier la viabilité du foets
paparce que c'est le Mississippi
ququi me restreindre à 15 semais
lele droit d'avoir, on peut jour
avavec une loi existante beaucop
plplus qu'avec une loi qui
n'n'existe pas.
DoDont il crcrée de toutes piècs
unune législation.
JeJe ne pas certain qu'on devrat
lélégiférer sur le droit mais
plplutôt sur l'accès.
- - Jonathan?
- - J'ai l'impression en entendt
MoMonsieur Trudeau et il se dit
quque la meilleure défense c'est
l'l'attaque parce qu'on regarde
l'l'autre côté de la frontière n
vovoyait que plusieurs prenez ca
popour acquis après 50 ans après
roroo contre Wade donc on se dit
ququ'au lieu de reculer on va
avavancer et on va venir sécurir
cecela.
JeJe reviens avec Alec sur le
dadanger de légiférer parce quea
raraison pour laquelle il n'y a
papas de critères légaux au Cana
cece que ça a bien été mis en
plplace et c'est bien balisé et
nonous n'avons pas de problème
avavec les avortements tardifs u
leles Zampito avec des comités
ététhiques et les médecins ne st
papas obligés de procéder à des
avavortements.
SaSans aller du côté législatif,
jeje ne déteste pas qu'on profie
dede ce moment pour augmenter ls
trtransferts en santé et d'aller
vovoir plusieurs provinces et ds
lolords qu'on va ajouter la
cacarotte et le bâton c'est-à-de
ququ'ils veulent plus ça va être
coconditionnés là que l'accès à
l'l'avortement soit accru qui et
ababscons coupe dans les
trtransports en santé au Québec
l'l'accès bien établi mais dans
d'd'autres provinces les plus
prproblématiques.
- - Il y a une compétence des
prprovinces essaient de donner e
seservice et donner cet accès et
çaça pourrait être difficile por
MoMonsieur Trudeau de légiférer
didirect demande, mais oui il na
papas tort, il y a certainemente
fafaçon de forcer les provincesà
êêtre un peu plus proactif et
dodonner le service.
AuAu Nouveau-Brunswick, le serve
n'n'est même pas couvert, il y a
trtrois cliniques sont privés et
leles femmes doivent payer poure
seservice.
L'L'accès aux services de santé
n'n'est pas garanti dans ce cas.
- - On verra!
LeLe REM je vous fais écouter
ChCharley Montillet veux un une
didire à Québec et Mme Plante li
avavais dit que tout allait bien
etet qui lui avait trouvé une
plplace autour de la table et
ququ'elle a appelé le gouvernemt
apaprès pour dire qu'elle n'aimt
papas le projet.
CHCHARLES EMOND président, Caise
dede dépôt et placement du Québc
- - Mais moi, j'ai appris, il ya
1010 jours, du gouvernement, qul
y y avait eu un appel de la
mamairesse comme comme quoi elle
vovoulait faire un autre projet.
MaMais ma dernière conversation
ilil y a à peu près 2-3 semaines
avavec elle, on n'a même pas eu
bebesoin de se rencontrer.
ElElle était ravie avec
lala proposition écrite
ququ'on lui avait soumise.
ElElle avait une place à la tab.
VAVALÉRIE PLANTE,
mamairesse de Montréal
- - Pour répondre à votre questn
sisi je suis une girouette,
lala réponse est non.
EtEt dans ce dossier-là,
enen fait, c'est deux éléments
trtrès, très distincts.
IlIl y a, un, la gouvernance
dudu REM de l'Est et il y a
lele tracé de REM de l'Est.
EtEt puis, dans le premier
dodossier qui est en lien avec
lala gouvernance, effectivement,
çaça avançait très bien.
EtEt moi je l'ai dit à plusieurs
rereprises d'ailleurs.
MaMais après ça, le tracé, lui,
ilil y avait quand même
dedes enjeux majeurs. Alors, mo,
jujusqu'à la dernière minute,
mmême en discutant avec
lele premier ministre, la CDPQ
ététait le constructeur,
cecelui qui faisait le REM de
l'l'Est, la nouvelle mouture.
- - Sur la gouvernance, elle dit
ququ'elle nous l'avait dit à
plplusieurs reprises et elle avt
auaussi dit qu'il y avait des
bobonnes nouvelles à venir.
LeLe manque de présence à la vie
dede Montréal.
InIndiqué le tracé sera modifié.
MaMartine, 24 ans plus tard vous
cecernez tout dans cette saga?
- - Monsieur Émond, il faut
cocomprendre sa frustration et
dédéveloppe une nouvelle experte
avavec le REM de l'Est et la
prpremière version c'est un peua
mimise en bouche et la deuxième
veversion c'était la pièce et
l'l'expertise se concrétise et
apaprès on pouvait vendre cela à
l'l'international et rentabilisr
l'l'expertise du REM de l'Est.
EsEst-ce que la décision de
reretirer le dossier à la Caisse
dede dépôt aura un impact sur sa
réréputation à l'international?
IlIls disent que non mais c'est
bibien possible!
LaLa maîtresse a raison, CAF de
dédécider ce qu'elle veut dans n
enenvironnement, et pour ce qui
esest du gouvernement du Québec
auaussi.
MoMonsieur Émond n'a pas mordu a
mamain qui le nourrit n'a pas vé
lele bureau du premier ministre,
mamais c'est là que ça s'est paé
etet c'est Monsieur Legault quia
didit oui à la mairesse de retir
lele dossier à la Caisse de dépt
etet Monsieur Legault a aussi ss
inintérêts, et s'en va en électn
ilil va avoir un projet porteur
ququi fait rêver quelque chose à
raraconter et des promesses
adadonnées en campagne électora.
- - Il ne veut pas de controvere
avavec une structure!
- - Tout est bien qui finit bien
popour Monsieur Legault.
- - Il ne veut pas de controvere
avavec une structure au centre-
viville, mais il ne faut pas fae
rrêver avec un projet parce que
çaça ne se produira pas d'ici sx
momois!
- - J'ai dit que c'était du géne
popolitique l'annonce du
gogouvernement parce qu'il aplat
dedes irritants au centre-villel
vivient sécuriser les citoyens e
l'l'Est de la ville se demande i
momoins de laissés-pour-compte t
onon ajoute un prolongement dans
l'l'ville de Laval et sur la rie
susud donc en campagne ils vont
popouvoir dire à bien des gens i
leleur font miroiter des
peperspectives ambulantes pour
l'l'avenir.
MaMais dans les 24 dernières
heheures, je pense que c'est un
cacamouflet de bon augure que
MoMonsieur Émond a servi, il
vovoulait s'assurer que la caise
nene soit pas trop entachée dans
cecette espèce de joute
hoholistique, mais je pense que
totout le monde a avantage à
cece contour nappage. le garde
lala réputation est affectée à
l'l'international et il est celi
ququi bénéficie des retombées
lolorsque la caisse des bonnes
afaffaires, si l'Ville de
MoMontréal, Mme Plante n'a pas
avavantage que ça perdure parce
quque au-delà du REM de l'Est, l
y y a le premier projet de crème
ququi va entrer en service dans
leles premiers mois de je pense
quque là tout avantage que les
rerelations redeviennent au taux
fifixe en apparence.
- - Et quant aux projets concre,
lala mairesse affirme qu'o'on ve
enencore deux mil 29 août 2031,
esest-ce que quelqu'un croit ce?
IlIl faut que les ministère des
TrTransports et la STM et la RTM
s's'entende!
- - J'imagine qu'il y a des gens
ququi y croient, il y a des gens
ququi croient au Père Noël mais
ilils ont 5 ans!
MoMoi j'y crois pas en tout cas.
CÇa fais combien de temps qu'on
anannonce la ligne bleue du mét?
OnOn se retrouve avec les mêmes
bubureaucraties qui ont géré ce
prprojet c'est-à-dire la STM la
RTRTM et les ministère des
TrTransports.
CÇa va prendre un porteur de
baballon claire, un bureau de
prprojet fort peut-être une
pepersonnalité qui mène ce projt
etet qui pourrait aller sur la
plplace publique et brasse les
chchoses, parce que si on laisse
leles mêmes personnes qui
plplanifient la ligne bleue gére
lele REM de l'Est il ne verra
jajamais le jour.
LeLe projet est loin d'être sur
leles rails!
- - Il reste 50 secondes!
JeJe l'impression qu'on avait un
didilemme entre projet imparfai,
ouou pas de projet pour un boute
tetemps.
C'C'est ça qui est malheureux!
- - C'est un projet qui va aller
enen campagne électorale, et ça
seserait enfin aimé donc il a ca
sosous le bras il pourra vendre
ququelque chose qui peut emballr
dedes gens à Montréal et les
séséduire et après on verra!
- - Les gens de l'Ouest attendet
totout ce temps-là